whenever i'm cooking i always make sure
there are vegetarian options
they can make do or they can [ __ ] off
[Applause]
you know zuckerberg says he's only
eating his own meat that he kills now
have you read that
with his bare hands yeah he's a monster
he tries to do one thing to alter his
modern lifestyle every year and this
year he says he's only going to
eat meat that he's actually killed and i
was wondering what are you adhering to
vegetarian strict vegetarian oh have you
done that
well i eat chicken
that's not vegetarian i'm not i said i'm
not strict i eat chicken and
steak
there's nothing that's better than a
soybean yeah you're right
which sounds better that or soybean
listen
some of the best meals i've had is that
mongolian thing over at dahmer's on
wednesday night
people talk about like don't eat
dolphins when they're in the tuna pick
out the dolphins
right
you gotta pick it out like
um but like you ever
look at you ever go to the shop for tuna
and like it says dolphin safe
and you kind of go like yeah but like
somehow you think it's not going to be
as good
like i want to do the right thing but
it's probably kind of bland with that
dolphin but here's the thing like why
not
kill and eat a dolphin why not oh
because
i don't [ __ ] get it if if you're a
tuna
[ __ ] you we're in you
so i don't really see the difference and
i think it's wrong to eat tuna
and dolphin and cows and everything but
i eat them
i eat them all because i don't
care that it's wrong
i totally think it's terrible but that's
not important to me
but it's terrible so what if it's wrong
it tastes good and i like the way it
feels when i eat it
so [ __ ] it what do you really like
animals miss yes
you do which ones are your favorite
every animal that's sweet
every single animal they all have life
you're right
100 right about that they don't all need
to
i feel like you haven't experienced
enough life-or-death situations with
animals
you know what i mean do you think an
animal cares about your life
you think a polar bear is going you know
what she's probably got backgammon on
tuesday maybe
i won't eat her
i'm just gonna sit here with this
coca-cola and sip it with my nephews
but i understand you like animals
because you know you live in the first
world and it's boring and we got to care
about [ __ ]
i get it i'm with you say again
i almost thought you said do you see me
i'm an animal
and i was
i was about to be like whoa
because you are asian right so that
would make you panda
a little bit right
no your third world
but your third world but you're from
america right you're born and raised
here
no where were you born philippines when
did you come here
uh when i was like eight years old oh so
you had some real [ __ ]
and in the philippines are there any
animals that they eat that we don't eat
[Applause]
here
it's not about win or lose
it's not about win or lose it's just
about understanding [ __ ] in the
philippines they eat dogs because they
don't care
as much about dogs right because they
don't have chipotle
they don't have chipotle they got
chihuahuas
because they get too hungry
[Applause]
[Music]
fido come come final come come final cup
right it right in there fido there we go
nice and warm nice and warm
when you look at vegetarians and you
look at vegan people uh
you know there's an astounding level of
fleshy
fat people that don't eat meat you know
what i mean
and they'll eat french fries because
it's made from potatoes and they're a
vegetarian but it's fried and they'll
say you know potatoes on good food
anyways as far as i know oh maybe i
shouldn't even say that
i don't want to be all oprah here and
get people to stop eating potatoes and
then the whole [ __ ] potato farm
farming industry sues me here at the
monday morning podcast um but there's
just a lot you know they
like [ __ ] just all carbohydrates and
[ __ ]
and they just stay away from meat uh i
think a lot of people love animals but
they hate reading
is what i've sort of learned from
looking at vegetarians and vegan people
you know so they don't eat meat but then
they don't really know what the [ __ ] it
is they're doing
but the people that do take the time
to do it right like nobody who lived in
this house
for a hundred [ __ ] years evidently
took the time to do something right ah
they didn't do that they just called
their [ __ ] friend to fix it didn't it
[ __ ] getting a permit [ __ ] it somebody
licensed
[ __ ] all of that what did they do
they just [ __ ] lived here they had a
problem they asked a friend and i think
a lot of vegans and vegetarians do that
they [ __ ] talk to people
rather than reading and that's what i do
because it's easier
it's easier than sitting down and
actually doing the [ __ ] work
so you know i see that you know
like can anybody if gundy your [ __ ]
head
can anybody tell you whether having an
egg is good for you or bad at this point
eggs have been good bad good and now
they're starting to be bad again while
people who are saying they're
good are [ __ ] you know they're duking
it's like the rubber match the rubber
game
whatever the [ __ ] it's called right um
so i'm gonna i'm gonna talk to a
nutritionist and i'm gonna i'm gonna
you know try to read up on it but it's
it's really dry
and if you actually look up [ __ ]
on becoming a vegetarian or or eating a
little like that
like a vegan or something i mean it's
just
hatfields and mccoy and i'm of course
between
the [ __ ] meat eaters the carnivores
and the vegetarian people and there's a
lot of money at stake
no pun intended sorry about that um
so i i think like the big farming
cattle [ __ ] people
you know they're trying to have all this
[ __ ] come up first
and then all the the tree hugging like
hey man
like you know trees are alive
man those [ __ ] people are trying to
say that you know eating meat is
is like like i saw this thing right what
they were saying
that this guy was trying to say that
like
animals get protein from eating plants
and when you eat an animal it's an
indirect protein because she should have
just gone directly to the plant
and it's like well then explain tigers
and they're [ __ ] you know mr universe
physiques
as far as i know which is i don't know
[ __ ]
so i should shut up right now and google
what what a tiger's eat
what do tigers eat
meat only well they're always in a bad
mood
can't even take a [ __ ] siberian the
species diet ordinary consists about 50
percent
wild boar meat doesn't that sound
delicious if they cannot get their paws
on some wild boar
they've been known to eat elk deer and
lakes
they're like wait what were you [ __ ]
with me for man
i didn't do nothing and sometimes even
bears
oh my god what size
jesus christ
that's a big thing in asia huh putting
like a bear and a tiger in a [ __ ]
cage and just
filming it if large sources of meat
are not readily available siberian
tigers will eat
rabbits fish and any rodents they can
get to
let's see okay well there's no meat in
that
too and that's the first thing i saw do
tigers eat
plants
what the tigers eat siberian the species
diet consists it's still this
uh tiger's diet eating tigers eat a
variety of prey
ranging in size from termites to
elephant calves
all that would break my heart to see a
baby elephant get killed
however an integral component of the
diet
are large body prey weighing 45 pounds
or larger such as moose d what do we
[ __ ] mean
moose and bear where the [ __ ] are those
things i thought they were
the moose were only over here deer
species
pigs cows horses buffaloes and
goats yeah well they have a different
digestive system
evidently because if you just [ __ ]
ate that that's ba they're basically on
the atkins diet right
get as much [ __ ] bacon as you want
tiger's looking at you like yeah i
realize that
i realized that um so anyways i'm gonna
try to [ __ ] uh
i don't know i'm gonna talk to a
nutritionist somebody who read all the
[ __ ] that i'm supposed to read
and maybe try to get them to tell me
some oh bill are you really gonna buy
books of nutrition like you're gonna
[ __ ] read them
do they have a lot of pictures
um anyways
i should probably read some advertising
i don't feel like [ __ ] doing that
[Music]
so
[Music]
you